hi I'm Angela Landis and I've been
acting professionally for the last 15 or
so years my mission from film courage is
to tell you the five things I do every
day to book acting work the first thing
I would do every day is focus on my
craft or the acting part of the job I
would be in class and if I'm not in
class I might be working on set another
thing I'm doing is just research on the
craft in general or the industry there
are so many like acting schools out
there or casting directors who give you
free tutorials online
there's no excuse to not constantly be
studying I also like to listen to
podcasts with directors or actors or
other people in the industry that I
admire and I can learn a lot that way
the second thing I do every day is focus
on the business aspect of the job that
means submitting myself on the casting
sites at least once a day since timely
submissions are more effective in
addition to self submitting I also tried
to make sure that all of my materials
are up-to-date and available for my
agent to look for jobs on my behalf
that's my resume my contact information
my profiles on the casting site my
website my IMDB page etc etc that I and
my agent have all the tools we need to
make submitting me for jobs possible the
third thing I do every day is PR or
marketing with social media that means
your marketing is free and easy and kind
of fun I try not only to promote myself
but to also engage with the people that
I respects in the industry social media
can be a little bit overwhelming for me
because it's kind of unless so I try to
keep it pumping myself the fourth thing
I do every day is I hire myself that
essentially means that I'm constantly
writing or developing or producing or
editing some project where I have cast
myself as one of the actors I not only
get acting work that way but I learn
about the industry and all the different
jobs on set it's also helped me build
relationships within the industry that
have led to more work I started small
producing webseries and short films and
just finished my first feature film
which has been purchased and released on
VOD just this last April it's called
boned it's a quirky story about an
actress me in the land of Hollyweird the
fifth thing that I do every day is I try
to turn off the business side and just
be a person with my dog go on hikes hang
out with friends lots of different
things I think it helps me build
relationships better when I have
something to say that's not just about
me and my last acting job and who I've
studied with and who I've worked with it
helps me not only just in the
relationship part of the industry but it
helps me with my character work when I
have explored other things in my life I
can apply those to my craft so those are
my five tips about how I look for acting
work every day thanks for listening and
break a leg out there don't forget to
check out bone at the movie com
you